On "The Big Bang Theory," Penny has
occasionally shared tidbits about her
quirky family from Omaha, Nebraska, but only a few
appeared during the show's 12-season run
— most notably Wyatt, Penny's father.
Along with having a brother, Randall, who
is best known for his history cooking meth,
Penny mentions having a sister a few times
in the show — the sister who drunkenly shot
her own husband, and gave Penny her
first bikini wax using melted crayons.
While Penny's brother, dad, and mom Susan
all attend Penny and Leonard's second wedding
ceremony in the first episode of Season
10, her sister is nowhere to be seen,
and is never even mentioned — a pretty big plot
hole, if you ask us. In Season 12, however,
we at least finally learn Penny's
mysterious sister's name: Lisa.
"Being your dad is the best
thing that ever happened to me."
"What about Randall and Lisa?"
"They’re okay."
*Laughter*